you had Jaylen Turner and Bobby green
and this kind of overshadowed a great
night of fights because the ref went but
did he die and we're like no he's like
damn there's a couple jobs where we can
kind of have brain farts and take your
time if you're an open heart surgeon
probably not if you're a chef not the
end of the world if you burn the steak
if you're a mechanic kind of go at your
own pace if you're NFL quarterback you
got to get moving if you're a ref in the
UFC you got to be on your stuff man you
can't have a brain fart or just zone out
or trying and see somebody die that's
what this guy did with with Jaylen
Turner and Bobby green I'm trying to
remember I'm trying not to be a prisoner
of the moment this might be the worst
stoppage I've seen late stoppage can you
think of another one I mean yamasaki was
notoriously known for it but his was
always like ah come on this one I mean
dude what are you doing yeah I felt so
bad for Bobby horrible yeah horrible
horrible